et
[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
comment il les a toutes s'il allait bien
mal et mieux alors toujours un nouveau
numéro d'on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
est toujours un superbe endroit à
découvrir
alors on commence comme ça oui d'accord
mais là oublie mon nom mon rasoir
pendant une semaine c'est pas grave
donc aujourd'hui on est chez jean-marc à
saint philippe et jean marc et va nous
faire une petite salade de palmiste on
va bien manger ce midi on va voir un
petit peu son jardin son domaine parce
que franchement c'est énorme
donc moi ce que je vous propose c'est de
me suivre 1 et puis devenir plus vite et
que de cerises très bon pour la fia est
très très bon pour la fia est bel et
bien allons voir jean marc t allons
[Musique]
wang livre génial alors déjà merci
d'accueillir nous devienne un petit peu
ça mouline la balle à nous les hoquets
de saint-philippe au baril ni paul cayre
parce que tout à l'heure on va connaître
pourquoi n'est pas le docteur amine
on connaît ma technique a mis dix mille
cas admis ce mois ci la bonne voie donc
l'endroit s'appelle le four à pain et
pour le coup c'est pas pour rien parce
que mes voix kung on a quand même
donc voilà donc dans maccoyii simon un
petit patrimoine
aujourd'hui c'est moi le gardien et
c'est un vieux four à pain là c'est la
bouche du foie et à l'arrière deux fois
il y avait un homme
d'accord mais le dom 1 est effondré et
donc à la place du nomes
ils ont construit une cité est d'accord
d'ailleurs la cité on a deux joueurs
près on va fêter ses cent six en six ans
[Musique]
quand on regarde un petit peu l'histoire
qui lie à au toit de chez nous au baril
il avait une ancienne usine sucrière qui
date de 1862 donc on peut essayer faire
le rapprochement entre ce four à pain et
l usine sucrière qui voudraient de
lefaux du village dont elle veut dire
que ces murs là segal et lassana
largement plus de 100 ans mais bien
largement plus imaginez bien que nous
nous pas le nom de pain le nom de la
petite fille la petite bouche du foie
voilà sa marmaille après ça patrimoine
[Musique]
en remontant la zot va découvrir un
petit jardin créole donc ici on va voir
des flops de l'année
l'idée aussi dans tout ça c'est ne pas
mettre aucun produit je le plante ce qui
pousse ces bons ce qui ne veut pas le
pouce et ben on va choisir d'autres
plantes et là quand les oiseaux vont
venir ou à des abeilles butinent et ils
sont dans leur univers tout est naturel
qu'on dit moi je vois que tu as de la
vanille on peut aller faire un petit
tour en voir et en parler voire eux
ben si tu veux on va fameux citoyen la
vanille t à quoi il va tout nous
expliquer cela va nuire mieux ce journal
[Musique]
cette venir à ses dégoûts sq été
fécondée vers le mois de novembre
mais après pour que la gousse mur il
faudra quand même attendre encore six
mois darcos le cycle il faudra compter
deux cycles d'une gousse de vanille ces
neuf mois d'accord au caucus est halal
bus c'est toi qui veux tu en voilà
l'accalmie ça nous a montré comment on
fait la fécondation est aujourd'hui
génération en génération perpétue tout
ça c'est de vanilla en fin de compte je
suppose que c'est du cpo du de la
consommation place aux aventures quand
même d'en bas c'est plus le comme j'ai
une petite venir et ça va être un peu la
consommation personnelle et puis une
petite partie et je vais le mettre sur
la table pour les touristes qui sont pas
sages et puis il faut dire que de toute
façon à saint-philippe s'il n'y a pas de
dany massé triste voilà façon à saint
philippe
là on est à une chasse à philippe on a
des cultures bien spécifique palmistes
vanille
[Musique]
et
jean marie yan tu connais pas assez les
vraies cela dit même si on en a des
magnifiques chants aussi work du monde
etc
c'est vrai ça chambre d'hote s'entend
car audi à plat qu'on voit ça allons
voir ça tu es folle et je vois ça je
passerai où je passe là je pense alors
[Musique]
donc je peux trouve rien faire grâce à
un étage à commencer donc c'est une
chambre double chaque chambre représente
un peu ce qu'on fait ici à saint
philippe là on est une chambre vanille
si on regarde au niveau des landais
chevet c'est le travail d'un artisan
local
la fête va quoi voilà de saint philippe
ici on va retrouver des petites
brindilles la petite veine principale du
palmiste d'accord est ici le battoir
[Musique]
oui
c'est pas tout - ou la nuit ou là dormi
ou la plus productive mais vous
connaissez ou vais me faire la cuisine
aussi aimé dit quelque chose qui est
très intéressant là je remarque me dit
que la cuisine aussi que ta gueule il
connaît ici à saint philippe
là où le coeur du palmiste donc quand il
fallait depuis fait manger sain philippe
rentables ou d'autres comme ça chez moi
là automatiquement les producteurs en
europe parmi sa table en rien le palm
hills
donc là jean marc bosetti domaine où tu
as tes paypal mais c'était de faire quoi
et coco voilà alors pas de risque ocovas
quoi parmi ce royal turkmène en fils
idéal à la sucette pas celle-là j'ai
quatre hectares 4 ha alors qu'elle
puisse pas me faire couper ou là bon
après bien par exemple celui là on peut
déjà avoir un petit show un bain alors
voyez
lass est coûteux et coupant vrai
voici cette pratique tandis que ça va
manger installable est là pour le coup
vous demain c'est celui là qui va finir
dans le petit qu'un report c'est ça
voilà
bonjour marc là nous sont donc des
champs dis moi tu m'avais dit que tu
avais préparé parce qu'on avait donc le
palmiste pour la salade des palmistes
pour le carry mais là pour le coup
du coup j'avais déjà rien que j'avais
coupé ce matin très tôt pour faire une
petite surprise c'est pour faire un
roulé de police roulait pas musulman vos
mauvais ça va alors donc déjà à la base
on n'est pas très gai ici ce que vous
voilà c'est que c'est un regret qu'elle
songe à rouler que tu donc ça l'état les
rames et après bâle a fait bouillir rat
palmiste entier rentrée mais ça va
reconstituer le palm hills titien
d'accord donc mais reprend les morceaux
ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant 100 euros la nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant fait
on va expliquer comment fait une bonne
salade de palmiste aux gens qui nous
regardent quand j'ai vu ça sur le marché
et ben arfa zola peut être acheté à
expliquer aux autres comme effet une
bonne petite salade bombe à la base
d'une bonne salade servant une
vinaigrette est fait avec le citron va
pas prendre le vinaigre
ici on en a deux c'est vrai ça dans mon
jardin salle et naturel après ne produit
rien d'essayer palmistes pareil
d'ailleurs fait naturellement donc le la
vinaigrette ou prend le citron 1 petit
oignon un petit peu de points celle ci
touche depuis le poids la mort quand
parce qu'elle est sympa marc lui non
plus nous leurs et après quand
vinaigrette et les prêts vie prend de
palmiste et là on aime parti il faut
connaître ils sont pas si vous que votre
ca dire est blanc là cette partie devant
là il faut pour m
[Musique]
ils m'ont mis un show biz comme ça
la méthode
ou la la la la la la le petit samoussas
savuth a fait maison bien sûr oui mais
ça ne sera pas miss amanda palmer les
petits manquements 2011 et voilà et le
rouler c'est ça la salade
voilà qu'on voit tout de suite goûté à
l'or d'amis fait honneur à aller à
amiens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
franchement tu n'as délice palmistes
songe faillite pas de qualité et un
petit jaune d'oeuf du citoyen tout
simplement à bien manger bien manger et
c'est le moment tant redouté qu'on
appelle l'interview de fin tu attends
dis moi comment comment tu es arrivé à
ouvrir ta petite ta petite chambre
d'hote accueillir des gens comme ça que
des tours ici que des réunionnais qu'est
ce qui t'a poussé à qu'est ce qui t'a
poussé à faire ça en fait donc bon c'est
une réflexion qui était fait en deux un
madame et moi c'est pas que tout cela
derrière chaque grand homme et moi la
femme donc pour l'idée c'était que des
pabx moi même je suis agriculteur et
dans un projet de diversification
agricole qu'il ya mon activité côté donc
revaloriser des projets que j'ai mal le
palm hills et notamment d'autres tels
que ben général moi je reste skier dans
le végétal leva quoi les palmistes royal
le shoot coco on peut trouver tout ça
ici on fera pas et donc si c'est que
pour moi le site s'ils s'y prêter pour
un don qu'il faut aussi lié à ça donc ma
famille on se dit mais pourquoi pas on
arrivé à un âge mûr c'était le moment ou
jamais et bien voilà donc l'esprit la
table d'hôtes c'est aussi manger local
et avec le plus souvent possible naturel
écoute connu comme sa ferme à midi au
revoir
ben voilà on parlera directement la
durée je me demande si je vais piquer
une tête directement tout râler mais là
ça va aller jean-marc merci ben merci à
vous en quoi ces petites visites et puis
au plaisir de te robert je reviendrai
voilà revoir
[Musique]
je
mi-juillet zone on vante les plains le
petit port palmistes le roulé aux
palmistes
un délice je précise qu'à deux
kilomètres vers le sentier de mare
longue
il y un sentier d'interprétation
botanique en même temps dans le sud
sauvage et à la piscine de l'autre côté
là pas mal de sentiers qui mènent vers
les forêts à saint-philippe ceux qui
veulent marcher dans les forêts etc
ne vous en faites pas il ya de quoi
qu'est ce que je peux dire d'autre très
important vraiment pas sorti de
l'auberge
et celle là elle est pour mon petit papa
serait georges oui alors moi je pars oui
mon vente et non musulmans
[Musique]